décidément on prend un grand bol d'air
dans ce journal puisque nous allons
maintenant au mondial du vent
une compétition qui rassemble les
meilleurs champions de kitesurf et de
windsurf du monde
ils s'affrontent à coups de figures
spectaculaires devant un public souvent
bluffé par leur virtuosité au portage
halo 4
léo lamberton françoise masson attendait
que ça se tire-t-il certes on met en
avant
c'est devenu le sport à la mode sur les
plages françaises
le kitesurf mélange de surf et de
cerfs-volants attire de plus en plus
d'adeptes
ici à leucate dans l'aude depuis dix ans
une nouvelle école se créent chaque
année super agréable c'est vraiment
ludique comme au sport très facile
d'accès là c'est encore la basse saison
donc ça va assez calme mais après
pendant la haute saison là on est
quasiment complet
le khat est aujourd'hui en france le
paradis des amateurs de surf depuis 14
ans en avril
les champions du monde entier se
retrouve ici un événement qui attire
désormais 168 curieux et si les sports
de glisse des colts aussi bien c'est
parce qu'ils sont dans l'air du temps
sont pas polluants
donc c'est vraiment le rêve ça ne
fonctionne qu'avec le vent c'est quelque
chose de très écologique de pas fait
pour l'environnement
loin d'être du vent le secteur est
devenue prospère à leucate
cela représente 150 emplois et pas moins
de huit boutiques qui de la planche à
voile au surf décline toute la gamme des
sports de glisse aujourd'hui on fait
deux fois et demie plus que ce qu'on
faisait il ya 15 ans mais ça fait partie
aussi sur le kitesurf depuis quatre ans
le stand up à l'heure donc aujourd'hui
on a des univers qui sont beaucoup plus
étendue c'est aussi pour ça que les
magasins aux demandes dernier né de la
famille venue tout droit de polynésie le
stand up paddle du surf debout avec une
pagaie
car c'est aussi la raison du succès des
sports de glisse en se renouvelant en
permanence ils élargissent leur public
et reste toujours dans le vent